Oh
hello and welcome back to the madness
weekly show with us today we have Kate
Murphy CEO of play - welcome thanks for
having me I thought we'd start off the
day by talking a bit about the Blitz
tournament after you've become the world
champion of rapid that was some crazy
days and you went right into blitz how
did that feel not having much time to
decompress after that win yes really
there were the rapid championship was -
it took a lot of out of me I didn't know
how to be ready for for the Blitz but
somehow I just had to go up there and do
my best so I didn't have any great
expectations are to start and my my
first few games were a little bit
tentative my first game against a young
russian grandmaster was very difficult I
probably had a losing position at some
point and then at the end we both have
very little time pieces were flying and
I came out on top fortunately in the
second game it was pretty even all along
I and I just beat him in drama gaining
that tissue by any means have lost then
the third game I played my my good
friend Doha facing a I I played a bit of
an arrogant all think against him just
to just work for fun I thought at that
point we were so early in the tournament
so why not try an experiment a little
bit
and you train with him right yes he has
been
he wasn't my my team before the World
Championship and also we had a training
session earlier this year I actually
gained a pretty normal position and then
at some point he repeated moves once and
there was really nothing useful I can do
to avoid it so I repeated and then he
didn't want the repetition and a draw he
explained to me well he'd get two
different explanations afterwards one
which was the most obvious one was that
he he felt that I tried to humiliate him
in in in the in the opening so we just
wanted to punish me and the other one
was that he didn't want that
the further the humiliation of me
stepping out of a repetition that's
clearly disadvantages for me and still
winning the game so the way the game
went it was a pretty normal position but
then I he gained a passed pawn which was
initially quite strong that I was able
to control it and eventually surround it
and and seize it and when win the game
with my extra point then I won - very
nice games that the inner road with
white and suddenly I was at five foot
five and at the top word how are you
feeling at that point I was feeling
better and better my play was I started
to flow in the first couple of games I
play very slowly but after in the fourth
and five fifth game I played very
quickly and very well generally it's a
sign that you're playing well
in blitz when you were playing quickly
because if you spend a lot of time then
your brains not usually this usually not
functioning as well
you're not thinking as fastest as you
should and blitz is not supposed to be a
struggle it's supposed to be free fun
kind of game yeah
then in the sixth round it was a draw
with my friend young the publisher he
played a kind of a ridiculous
opening but then I failed to punish him
he getting slightly better position he
put a lot of pressure on me both on the
position position and on the clock but I
managed to just defend them get into a a
drone position after a while it was kind
of a premonition of what was the calm
that he was in excellent Foreman and
would score a lot of points so then I
beat Vietnamese player Lake work in the
next game first I was a little bit
better then she was a little bit better
than I regained the initiative and had a
very safe advantage where there was no
chance of losing but also very difficult
away so I pressed for a long time and we
both had little time I was playing
partly to confuse him partly with real
plans and then at the end when he lost
some time my position was actually
winning I'd managed to do tricky but
however there have been 51 moves without
any pieces captured or pawns moved but
there was absolutely no way he could
keep you know that since in in blitz you
don't write down your moves and so
but you remember this no I'd no idea I
only saw it afterwards now I checked the
game with the computer and at the end
the computer is saying zero zero zero
and I was like what my position is
completely way but then I saw yeah it's
just because there are there have been
15 or so but it was good except what
what you need to do if really I just
keep on fighting and outlast your
opponents well yeah
you sometimes hear kind of wincleaner
cleanly and then you just have to
outlast life
then came the tragic moment from against
young Chinese player Lucian way which
who whom I've barely heard of I've heard
the name that I knew enough nothing of
the way he played but considering that
he had scored six points from seven
games against opponents who were all
higher rated on him he must have done
something right initially he didn't
confirm that that feeling since he
played pretty badly in the opening I had
an advantage of one 1/2 minute on the
clock which is a lot considering that
were playing three minutes gates and a
vastly superior position and and then I
just I just made one careless move that
exposed my king and from then on he he
had initiative and he won the game that
was that was a huge block but then I
finished the day nicely with with two
wins and drawing with with with a knife
from 11 I was nevertheless
and then preparing for the next day
after such an intense day of so many
games what did you do to get ready for
the next day
I knew my next opponent was going to be
a garret my from from Germany who I knew
from before was I pretty accomplished
let's player I played in many many times
on different internet sites so I knew it
wasn't going to be easy
oh I only tried to prepare a little bit
for that game because I didn't know so I
prepared a little for for that game I
had a plan then decided that pun was a
bad one with a different before the game
or during the game decided that I
decided here in the game and I just like
to do this position but it quickly
normalized I felt that I was wearing my
work well on my way to playing in then I
made some one terrible decision opening
up the kingside and his PC just came
pouring in with lots of activity and I
was in huge trouble and then at some
point he made a mistake and I exploited
my only chance which was to go on a long
trip
with a knight all the way to to the
Queen side attacking his sweet holiday -
and fortunately for me it worked and and
I won the game so through the rest of
the day I kept on playing some very
strong opponents I said I'm on that
plate
I played Aronian I tried Grisha
I played rossovich actually those those
are the games that I I drew on the list
on the last day and I drew those for
gays and then it was getting quite close
at that point yeah I mean I was that was
okay by me him I was worse than most of
those
so I didn't object to drying them at all
were you still feeling confident I felt
that I was playing okay but I was
definitely feeling less confident by the
fact that Napoleon was just winning
every single game which which was
incredible I mean I you can expect
someone to to win a couple of games and
roll out three games in Robbins he won
six games in row against very strong
opposition and some of them like the one
against unarmed just drew drawn it
completely crazy because he had a much
worse ending
eirick ending and that he he really
managed to defend it very well then
anong yeah just went nuts and lost the
game is that which really really annoyed
me at that point um but I mean what what
could I do
I didn't particularly lose my
objectivity at that point in Europe I
had to continue to play relatively well
and actually I thought I managed to play
quite okay towards the end looking at my
game in retrospect I saw that I missed
quite a lot but that happens when you're
playing fast yes and what I learned from
earlier blitz tournaments is that it
doesn't really matter so much if you're
not playing that well as long as you
have the impression that you're playing
well and as long as your opponent thinks
that you're playing well then you might
not just necessarily have to make all
the right moves well
they're more likely to blender or not to
take their own chances basically so then
key was my was the third to last round
against my bed oh I was under huge
pressure in that game
then it became a time scramble and yet
we were both very low on time I had to
pull down but that wasn't really an
important factor because the position
was quite complicated than that point I
said I trap he felt it fell into it and
I won then I went over to watch yawns
gaming and he couldn't beat Corriveau
from formative from a very good position
it wasn't that easy to win but he
complained about that afterwards to me
but then I was again in late and in the
next game I would face another Russian
Sega UD who had done very well under on
the last day but nevertheless it was
someone I expected a bit while young
would play alone young with his black
again my name is particularly expecting
to win so then I was feeling confident
where my own game went beyond my wildest
expectations I mean I won in like 17
moves with with black after 800 and then
I could see in John's game he was being
pressured with with no particular
counter chances and obviously that at
that point I I felt pretty good about my
chances and seeing as he blundered at
the end I lost again
it increases the Katya in the last game
I was one point ahead of the politician
Nakamura I didn't particularly need to
do much legislate a very quiet game and
then at some point she went crazy and
I'm blundered upon then I thought well
Paul I'm at it I might as well win the
game so I wrapped up and and and one
turn one point at issue so how does it
feel now that you are in the world
champion and all three time controls
undefeated sir it feels very good
especially so I felt that I managed to
do very well in Dubai especially in the
Blitz 17 from 21 it's it's yes it's
really a great score for me my blitz
rating is now through the roof and I
have frequently well not frequently but
at least sometimes failed in shorter
time controls before and I've been able
to show now that ability at slower time
control often translates into great
thinking and I'm very very pleased
thanks man thank you